ok
par exemple bien sûr mais ils n'ont pas
voulu jeu ils m'ont saouler alors je
vous raconte un truc à maxime guînes il
a même voulu me donner 50 balles pour ya
une scène yann il ya le ya le coffre
fort qui est là et avec lui
s'te plaît chez lui pour donner ou pas
au top j'écoute maxime je ne peux pas
que le bébé parce que si je te le donne
à toi je dois donner à tous les autres
et là il sort un billet de dix balles je
vous jure que c'est pas vrai il me sens
vraiment bien de dival vas-y que je te
donne du bal à jeudi jules alors j'ai
dit non non dans les transmissions de
balle selon et là qu'est ce qu'il a fait
il a été retiré 56 et le pot il est
revenu avec ça et il m'a tendu un billet
50 balles je ne peux pas faire ça et
ontologiquement je ne peux pas vous avez
préféré les et les jeter de oui et donc
il a voulu me donner 50 balles pour dû
rendre son portable mais c'est pour ça
que j'adore incorruptibles saclay est
secoué par une violente tempête a bien
sûr pas le savait parce qu'il y avait
donc balances ton post avec en invité
principal marlène schiappa alors on est
très content de vous voir cyril j'ai
remarqué mais bon au bout d'un moment
elle avait envie d'aller dormir
oui ces cas là elle a oublié que vous
bah en fait même après 7 heures
d'antenne de goût vous en foutez vous
pouvez enchaîner sur la présentation de
gym direct ça vous dérange pas alors une
personne normale même du gouvernement à
minuit ça veut dormir dès 22h55 capa se
fait déjà du souci parce qu'elle sent
l'entourloupe arriver si nommé deux fois
aux césars sarah abitbol eric zemmour le
sujet retraite
donc voilà vous avez du boulot ordinaire
jusqu'à 4 à rignac et sais pas il est 22
heures 55 à minuit vous êtes dans votre
livre vous inquiétez pas tout de suite
alors si vous essayez de rassurer
marlène schiappa mais vous dites même
plus leurs pieds pour qu'elle parte
enfin direct viendra là dessus tous
ensemble dans un instant pour la
dernière partie de balances ton post
donc jeudi au ministre il ya un petit
peu de pub ensuite la troisième partie
ensuite ils pourront aller dodo parce
que demain une grosse journée monde chez
apple continuation
ça va pouvoir aller se coucher un jour
puisqu'on est quand même jeudi matin
franchement ils font beaucoup beaucoup
ça fait six heures qui sont directes
ouvertes à coucher à minuit il est
minuit 34 j'étais alors chilienne alors
là bas donc sourire carnassier
[Rires]
finalement l'émission stamina min 49 et
je rappelle votre promesse lui vous êtes
dans votre livre vous inquiétez pas ça
va et
à 49 minutes d'écart ça va ça passe ça
va c'est vrai que ça parce que vous
n'êtes jamais fatigué incroyable non
mais c'est vrai ça c'est odette massy
gens font ce qui est vrai et ce qui est
marrant c'est je me suis dit à 18h quand
j'étais avec vous là j'allume la télé
une heure du matin des encore là mais
c'est fou alors c'était la deuxième fois
que marlène schiappa venez donc je passe
plus de temps ici que chez moi mais moi
je vous dirai demain le nombre d'heures
que vous faites chaque semaine ici ah
ouais j'ai calculé ça lucien oui même si
c'est une demain vous verrez alors
marlène schiappa elle est venue donc
pour la deuxième fois dans balances ton
post est forcément vous l'avez réserver
de belles surprises comme jean messia ah
oui ou des français qui avaient envie de
débattre avec elle elle avec une soirée
mouvementée on va voir au sens
cyril hanouna vous aviez envie de lui
poser plein de questions des questions
dans l'esprit de celle des journalistes
politiques
jean pierre elkabbach et karine le
marchand vous aimeriez voir quels
ministères parler de sharp a d'ailleurs
vous c'est quoi vos ambitions alors êtes
vous êtes heureuse tant que ministre a
trop fatigant aussi à jean luc mélenchon
et marine le pen vanté pour voter pour
qui jean luc mélenchon bench apple est
très forte ce qui arrive à parler en
même temps qu'une autre personne sans
que cela perturbe et enfin et en termes
d'immigration et marc les chapeaux comme
tout le monde est devenu une immense
peine deux journées siala ministre avait
carrément se transforme en institutrice
et gens mais si on élève tout penaud il
ya des femmes comme valentine monnier
qui parle des dizaines d'années après et
une fois qu'il ya prescription et donc
nous notre devoir de responsables
politiques
si ça vous intéresse pas les questions
des victimes de violences sexuelles vous
ne vous dis tranquillement je m'adresse
à l'espace 2000 ce matin the miz de
grand remplacement
laissez-moi terminal f laissez moi tu es
un menu et ça va bien se passer
ça fait mal
c'est fait
j'ai vécu un moment formidable je suis
quand même à gagner de la mise il ya le
gard jean messia parce que maintenant
elle est celle qui vient et vous montrer
des trucs dans son ton tutelle et a vu
ce qu'on dit de moi c'était quoi
l'espace campagne qu'il voulait montrer
tweet ou les gens le le le le voilà à
l'insulter c'est donc moi voilà et
pendant ce temps là il y avait marqué le
shabak des mois on est à l'école et à
l'école sont géniales dehors alors vous
savez que vous aviez à vos côtés dans
bien sûr jean messiaen on aime le voir
et vous retrouver ils ont été musclés on
sent que ne pas pouvoir pendant un mois
ça vous manque franchement alors avant
de voir ce qui s'est passé je dis vous
ai fait un petit récap des épisodes
précédents
il ya deux personnes que tout oppose
doivent se parler malheureusement ça m'a
rappelé un des films préférés
[Musique]
18h40 noté pmp jeu des séries le nom
était impatient de revoir jean messier
et on aura bien sûr jean messia qui me
voient comme chaque semaine fait occuper
de lui avec la passer au guichet
morisien en tout cas idéal mais il va
bien on pas et que souris est ma passion
alors je comprends cette impatience car
c'est chaud à chaque fois qu'il vient
comme quand julien odoul du
rassemblement national avait planté
l'émission est bien entendu jean messia
qu'habite l'état joue dessus du studio
l'aveyron place n'avait pas regretté
l'état
julien houle nous a plantés au dernier
moment
enfin voilà les lire quoi sortez les
pierres non je le tenais va pas
recommencer
jean messia déjà au plus haut point
pourquoi le déformer n'est pas là
justement pourquoi en parler s'il est
pas là bas parce qu'il est pas là vingt
mille votes
si vous l'apprendra comme un sapin de
tir est engagée je vous en fais un autre
de sondage c'est bon mais surprise de
yassine est la plus ample connaissance
et quatre jours montraient bien sûr
c'est vrai tu veux lancer la plus grave
à place l'agent
très
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors replacer le contexte voir
l'ambiance est très amical quand
rencontre à chaque fois donc je dis
c'était encore plus amicales alors si
vous êtes un grand fan de michel drucker
et pourtant quand vous recevez un
habitant rire c'est pas le même style
d'accueil quoi franchement alors pour
vous montrer les échanges entre vous et
jean messia jeudi j'ai décidé de vous
imaginer en 30 ans représentent
attendent une nouvelle émission
s'appelle vivement jeudi
[Musique]
une fourmi sia est le recordman bien sûr
les invitations dans ballon à chaque
fois ça a cartonné au moi je m'essaye
les consciences qui date tout et tous
les deux d'accord mais sur rien alors
vous êtes trompés sur les chiffres
puisque je ne suis pas milla est arrivé
en tête un an dans cette émission si si
si si c'est pas sur twitter si c'est
même presque 50 ans et plus étaient 70
voilà donc pour vous dire que vous avez
dit une grosse connerie chez jean marc
morandini
voilà donc une fois de plus mais bon
c'est pas grave quand j'avais 20 ans
choquée parce que je voudrais également
la vigne bien entendu de genlis ya moi
c'est pareil on vous dira non pas
aujourd'hui qu'on dira hanouna bah si
vous voulez pas perdre à tous nos maux
se déroulera en france vont reprendre à
la française où ça aussi c'est raciste
pado voilà donc à nous n'a pas très bien
ce gars qui peuvent en la parole tout se
paie en 45 minutes est à dire au final
j'ai pas dit un mot depuis toner
mentionnés ci-haut voyez mon fou il est
faux afflelou les fous j'en mets ça il
en boucle se sont prétendus manques de
parole il va en profiter pour postuler
lui aussi pour la grosse rigolade
je viens juste de dire que ça fait une
heure et demi que j'attends la parole
heureusement j'ai des origines
égyptiennes parce que j'ai cinq mille
années de résignation derrière moi donc
ça me permet de patienter facilement
vous me donnerez quand la date de votre
one man voix
cette heure d'émission n'y a plus de
limite entre vous il ya plus de
vouvoiement n'y a plus rien qui vous
arrive ça y est c'est vivement jeudi
parce qu'on a fini de parler de
l'arrivée georges en m'utilisant méchant
et de la région la réserve se sont
accrochés par tout va bien je n'ai pas
les gens beaux chalets seront jusqu'au
gouvernement
j'ai loupé gens quand je te donne pas la
parole mais tu bois tu parles tu me l'a
pas donnée pendant une heure et demie
mes frères je me venge que les données
tu nous as fait ton concert mais ne pas
nous a fait tout est ici tu veux créer
ma vitre av 2 minutes l'attend best-of
l'a donc à rennes
[Musique]
incroyable
[Applaudissements]
j'aurais l'air quand même
mine de rien et je redis il est très
courageux de venir à chaque parent oui
et est ce que ça va lancer une émission
de débat et on a besoin aussi d'avoir
aussi la parole de jean bessière et
voilà parce qu'il s'en prend plein la
gueule ce fait des tons sous mon vrai qu
il n 5 quand même nom mais soit il il a
du courage de venir vous la mairie son
opus vous le diront la paix l'après-midi
pour le soir jeudi voilà les y est ce
que vous y a rien à [ __ ]
s'il n'était pas là à
il manquerait pas grave moi match
écrivait si je fais sur l'anniversaire
de 4000 watts de son talent enfin un
truc de ouf je ramène tout le monde et
khaled tout ça pour lui si szczyglo pour
finir dans ma loge temps passe il se
passe beaucoup de choses alors chaque
lundi vous fait un petit résumé en une
minute trente avec ambiance ton post
d'habitude l'ambiance aux balances ton
post c'est ça non ne va pas me faire le
coup de la soirée que tu le veuilles ou
non j'ai répondu à la côte nord mais
comparaison n'est pas raison et la dent
mais très mauvais exemple deuxième chose
pour la première fois jeudi vers 1 yann
intervenons discriminés par le courant
n'avait russe a fait une demande
incroyable balance topo c'est devenu
ballon jetons bisous
merci s'érige peut demander une petite
faveur alors tout ce que tu veux sauf de
l'argent on un peu rejetés dont je
voulais savoir si madame la ministre
voulait bien me faire une petite bise
pour retrouver le vrai ballon ce ton
post
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et sur le plateau a découvert une
personne un ami d'eric naulleau
j'habite à bagnolet la ville de raqqa de
garrido et même quand tu allais pas lara
qu'elle s'est quand même ça fait savoir
à quel garrido comme maire alain paquet
garrido elle est bien gentil mais on la
voit jamais sur bagnolet à la fois sommé
ces moments raquel garrido retraite
regrette d'avoir quitté l'émission oui
alors vous n'avez à mon avis rien on la
regrette pas à bagnolet ou là là c'était
une fête là pour se défendre voilà
et je dis bon je trouve faussée sont
tombés en émissions de dédicace comme à
la radio et moi syrie je voulais passer
un petit message à charles olivier
bourges au de la voix du nord pour le
remercier d'avoir mis en valeur mon
histoire merci et moi je voudrais dire
juste que je vends une bx leader
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]